hello
your racist sexist homophobic
transphobic bigoted islamophobes how are
you people
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message
and in case you didn't hear about it
there was a
presidential debate last night and this
thing was
pretty much a disaster on all fronts if
anyone
that you watch on youtube or on
mainstream media
or someone that you might listen to
their podcast or your neighbor or your
mother
or anyone else tells you that they
gleaned anything out of that
thing that made them feel better about
the future of the country or made them
feel
that uh that this is the right format
for getting forth ideas that are going
to help
lead us into the next decade into the
next century
that person is an idiot um so we're
gonna be deciphering some of the the
craziest stuff
that happened from last night uh i did
do a post
debate show last night which was viewed
already over
000 times it's got over 500 000 views
on youtube so i am glad to see that
people
are starting to wake up or there has
been a mass awakening
people are tuning out of mainstream
media as you should
it is almost all complete nonsense i am
a guy
in my office with my one producer right
there my dog is the executive producer
clyde he's outside right now
and uh director who's working remote and
i'm just telling you what i think and i
think
that you're probably going to feel a
little better about the world or at
least make a little
you'll have a little more sense about
what just happened i mean good
god that was insane last night and then
i would say the only thing more insane
than the debate itself and the fighting
and the screaming and
you're a racist and just all of the
usual
nonsense like it almost felt like all
the stuff that we've been talking about
for the last couple years it was all
it all just like burst forth into like
this orgy
of just grossness not a good orgy you
know what i mean like an orgy could be
good but not a good orgy was just like a
gross orgy like an orgy that people were
like
ah that's too much it was just a lot of
that uh so we're gonna we're gonna
decipher all that i got a couple clips
obviously we're going to play trump's
response on the white supremacist
question
and i want to play some stuff that might
give it uh if you're a journalist out
there watching you might want to do
what i'm about to do we're going to give
it context
that's when you sort of frame something
within a larger period of time
so that people have a better sense of
what is really happening so we're going
to play that we'll do the
the critical race theory one there was a
a line because i can get almost anything
to reference back to star wars there was
a line that joe biden said that was very
emperor palpatine-ish so we're gonna get
to that
and a bunch more but this reuben report
direct message
is brought to you by second thoughts
this is a new board game
that they sent us a couple weeks ago and
my team and i actually played a couple
days ago we had a little bit of whiskey
and if you're ever going to play a board
game i recommend whiskey not if you're
not if you're underage i'm talking about
for you adults out there that that do
play board games
and second thoughts is this year's new
favorite party game that's sure to be a
hit
with all your friends on family game
night
the play of the game calls for each team
to quickly create a list of words for
their opponents to decipher
leading to hilarious but puzzlement and
laughter
a puzzlement that's a word simply put
it's a classic word
guessing game with a unique twist that
allows players to personalize content
with their voluminous
sense of word smithery or just their
witty and warped imaginations each round
of second thoughts is a hilarious
high-speed attempt to stump the other
team
both teams create a list of five things
using letters revealed from the color
dice be witty and wise but don't take
too long
because time is of the essence michael
you've got to scroll for me
it's not on your side the amount of time
it takes your team to create the list is
exactly how much time your opponent's
guests
get to guess them second thoughts the
quick thinking verse fast talking party
game i did a little fast talking right
here
get yours today at second
thoughtsthegame.com second
thoughtsthegame.com or at your local
target store
and now let's get to the news and by the
way the second thoughts guys the reason
that they wanted to sponsor the direct
message is because they're fans of the
show so this is one way we can fight
cancel culture right it's like if you've
got an interesting product
or service or whatever it might be
if if you help support some of the shows
that are getting the ideas you care
about
um then you've done a little something
so show them some love and it really it
really is fun
okay let's get to the debate it was a
debacle
uh the entire thing was a debacle even
you know something's a debacle when
even the partisans on both sides were
like
that was rough now for the most part the
real trump people are saying trump
mopped up
and you know the real biden people are
saying biden mopped up
but as i was saying last night what you
really want to figure out after a debate
is did any of the undecided people
however many of them
actually exist but and not only how many
undecided people but the undecided
people who are actually going to vote
because if you're
undecided at this point that means
you're probably pretty apolitical
so that you may be less inclined to vote
but so how many of those people
are then going to be moved now it's it's
hard i think
to have said you watched that debate you
didn't know
who you were going to vote for and
suddenly you were like you know
that guy whoever it was
made a lot of sense and i'm definitely
voting for them
uh so you know when you hear a lot of
the post game debate and it's this one
won like that's not really what the
question is like someone obviously can
win a debate but what does that actually
translate to in the real world okay
so i want to throw to a couple clips uh
and this is the
the first one is the most important one
because this seems to be what the media
narrative is
that trump did not condemn white
supremacy so we're gonna do two things
here um and i cannot believe that i have
to do journalism i'm not a journalist
i'm just some guy but we're gonna do two
things here we're gonna play the exact
clip and then i'm gonna actually show
you the text because there was a lot of
crosstalk
and it was a little hard to decipher
exactly what was going on so we're going
to
play the clip and i'm going to show you
the text i'll read it back to you slowly
so you can decide for yourself what did
trump do did he not
condemn white supremacy did he condemn
white supremacy what the hell high what
the high hell happened
so here is the the white supremacy
question from last night's debate
you have repeatedly criticized the the
vice president for not specifically
calling out antifa and other left-wing
extremist groups but are you willing
tonight
to condemn white supremacists and
militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to do specifically
i would say almost everything i see is
from the left wing
not from the right what are you what are
you what are you saying i'm willing to
do anything i want to see peace
sir say it do it say it do you want to
call him
what do you want to call him give me a
name give me a white surprise
and write pressure boys stand back and
stand by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what somebody's got to do something
about antifa and the left because this
is not a right-wing
problem this is a lefty director this is
a left wing
okay so it's a little messy particularly
at the end of the clip but now i want to
throw up the actual text of what was
said and i'm just going to reread it for
you and i think if you actually
see it and if i kind of reread it
without the crosstalk i think it might
kind of help so wallace
are you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists
and militia groups trump sure okay
so that kind of sounds like he might
have condemned white supremacist groups
wallace and to say that they need to
stand down
and not add to the violence in a number
of these cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland trump sure
i'm prepared to do it but i would say
almost everything i see
is from left wing not from the right
wing i'm willing to do anything
i want to see peace wallace then do it
sir
biden do it say it trump
what do you want to call them give me a
name wallace
white supremacists and right-wing
militias biden proud boys
trump proud boys stand back and stand by
but i'll tell you what somebody's got to
do something
about antifa on the left okay so this
clip
obviously is the one where everybody
saying trump refused to condemn the
white supremacists now first
let me just say this trump's mistake
here
was because he he actually is a student
of the media if trump's a student of
anything it's of the media
so if trump wanted to just save himself
a headache and i know hindsight is 20 20
and when you're on the fly and there's a
lot of crosstalk it can be difficult to
do
trump almost needed to just repeat the
question like if you remember in fifth
grade
you'd get like you get a test and they
would ask you a question they'd say
repeat the question and then give the
answer
trump almost needed to say will i
condemn the white supremacists
i will condemn the white supremacist
this is me donald j
trump right now condemning all the white
supremacists
now i'm not saying that that would have
solved all of this because
nothing ever solves all this and we've
you we've so degraded the word racist
that you once you throw it on somebody
it's just become meaningless so
half the time when they call someone a
racist i'm like oh that person obviously
isn't a racist
and biden by the way did call him a
flat-out racist in the midst of it we'll
get to that
in a little bit on the critical race uh
uh critical race theory stuff
so look did biden condemn the white
supremacists
the first thing he said was sure so he
did um
now he did not say the exact sentence
and then at the end
see i think what everyone's getting hung
up on is this proud boys thing
because chris wallace who i don't envy
his position as
an interviewer and a moderator i don't
really envy it i would gladly do the job
i really would and i would try the best
i could to be impartial in everything
else but there was such chaos and and
crosstalk and this this actually wasn't
even
one of the moments that really got out
of hand but chris wallace in the
question never asked anything about the
proud boys
i don't even feel like i need to talk
about the proud boys the proud boys
aren't the ones burning down the cities
these are antifa and blm associated
groups that are burning down the cities
we all know this we've all seen a
zillion of the videos and no matter what
joe biden says
antifa is not just an idea and an idea
doesn't burn down a city
people burn down cities people burn down
buildings people stop
traffic and don't let people pass people
punch people and assault people at
restaurants and
a bunch of other stuff not just an idea
so if we had an honest
media an honest media would be doing two
things right now they'd be honestly
looking at what trump's response was
do you condem white supremacy the first
thing he said was sure
then it devolved into this thing where
it got caught up in well what do you
want me to call
it um and then i think when biden said
proud boys
trump's mistake was addressing that
instead of just saying he should have
just found out said i condemn white
supremacist that's it he should have
said i've done it before
i did it after charlottesville we'll get
to that clip in a second i've done it
before
and i'll do it again so look of course
the media is running with this thing
because it
fits their narrative perfectly and i
think the proud boys thing really
confused it and i also think that
trump's lines stand back and stand by
i'm not i just don't even know what he
meant there
was he really telling proud boys i'm not
even totally sure what powerboys is
but like was he really telling this
group he will stand back
and stand by like meaning you'll have to
do something at some point like he's
more than happy to use the government
to use the feds to use the national
guard if necessary i don't think trump
needs
a group the proud boys or any other
group to do his dirty work it's just not
like that
that's actually quite different than
what's happening on the left where biden
really is refusing to condemn antifa
antifa is the one
actually causing violence right now and
he won't even say that they're an
organization and we know that they're
obviously an organization
so oddly i think this morning all the
clips were about is trump are racist
i think the biden team and the messaging
and the media because they can't control
themselves
they sort of overshot the target here
and they went in so deep on this
that now it's gonna start coming out
that wait a minute antifa
is just an idea and trump actually did
if you watch the clip
condemn the white supremacy stuff even
if he did it in a slightly butchered way
i mean the guy speaks in a stilted
manner it's just
it's just how it is but i want to show
another clip because joe biden said at a
different point during this that the
entire reason he got into the race
because remember he didn't get in four
years ago right he was the vp at the
time he could have gotten in that would
have generally been the time
to to get in right that's what al gore
did uh after bill clinton that's what uh
george h.w bush did after ronald reagan
etc that would have been the time but he
said
he didn't get in then he did get in this
time because of trump and
charlottesville and white supremacy
that was the whole point of his campaign
and by the way when when biden launched
his campaign
that's exactly what he said that it was
because of the white supremacist stuff
that happened after charlottesville so
now i'm going to show you a video that
the mainstream
i am not a freaking journalist but i'm
going to show you a video
that that mainstream media refuses
to show and you tell me if trump
condemned the white supremacists
at charlottesville or not let's throw to
the clip and you had people and i'm not
talking about the neo-nazis and the
white nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
but you had many people in that group
other than
neo-nazis and white nationalists okay
and the press has treated them
absolutely unfairly
now in the other group also you had some
fine people but you also had trouble
makers
and you see them come with uh with the
black outfits
and with the helmets and with the
baseball bats
you gotta you had a lot of bad you had a
lot of bad people in the other group too
that was unfair i'm sorry i just
understand what you were saying you were
saying the press has treated
white nationalists unfairly i just
understand what we were saying there
were people in that rally and i looked
the night before
if you look they were people
protesting very quietly the
taking down of the statue of robert e
lee
i'm sure in that group there were some
bad ones the following day it looked
like they had some
rough bad people neo-nazis
white nationalists whatever you want to
call them but you had a lot of people in
that group that were there to
innocently protest and very legally
protest because you know
i don't know if you know they had a
permit the other group didn't have a
permit
so i only tell you this there are two
sides to a story
i thought what took place was a horrible
moment
for our country a horrible moment but
there are two sides of the country
okay i really really hope that you've
seen that clip already i i hope
uh that you've seen that and that you
will share that clip
or you'll send this very video to people
that are completely confused by this who
still believe
that donald trump trump said there are
good people on both sides what he was
referring to he first
said the neo-nazis and the white
supremacists
should be condemned totally he later
after the question said that they are
bad people what he was talking about
when he said both sides is that there
are people on both sides of the debate
as to what you would do
about a robert e lee statue and that
some of the protesters actually had
permits to be there
and by the way you may not like people
who want robert e lee statues to be up
there but they're allowed to protest for
it the same way
you're allowed to protest against it so
why will they not show that clip on cnn
jake tapper you're the last guy there
with a flickering sense of
of uh decency as far as i can tell show
the clip
show the clip why am i doing your job um
brian stelter wolf blitzer any of you
people sho
lemon show that just show that clip and
let people decide whether trump
was before the neo-nazis and the white
supremacist which he
said he condemns totally now
the reason that this is important this
isn't me carrying water
for trump this is that the media refuses
to tell you the truth and if the media
is going to keep refusing to tell you
the truth well you're going to keep
tuning out of that and tuning into
things like this but then that becomes
even more dangerous because we're all
going to keep going to our silos and as
i've been saying for a while we
basically have a war on reality
right now because people just pick what
they pick what they
believe is true based on preconceived
notions and at some level you can't
blame them because the media is just
so incredibly crappy on top of
everything else
uh then the biden team from the official
at joe biden twitter account they
tweeted out
this thing today about joe about uh
trump refusing to condemn white
supremacy and they put
a picture of kyle rittenhouse who is the
kid
in uh kenosha we did a video on him last
week
and there as far as i know there is no
evidence that this kid whether he did
the right thing or wrong thing
let the people decide and we i'm happy
to discuss that further and it seems
like it's much more complex than the
media was originally allowing
but as far as i know there is no
evidence that
this kid is a white supremacist okay so
uh i think
i think biden may have really really
stepped in it on that one and if
and it sounds like this kid has a pretty
good legal team
and he should definitely be looking into
a defamation lawsuit or something else
like that
but we just let people say these phrases
you're a racist you're
you're a white supremacist as if it has
no meaning and they're just
absolutely destroying lives so
again i hope you share this clip if that
was news to you or if it's news to
somebody
that you know and we all have these
people in our families and our friends
it's important for context it's it's
just important for context
so trump said sure last night did he
butcher it by not saying a full sentence
i absolutely condemn white supremacy
yeah
rob smith by the way who's been on the
show a couple times um
he set out a nice little twitter thread
of
of the series of times that trump has
condemned racism and anti-semitism
and the rest of it and it's like again
the media
stop thinking that cnn is a news
organization stop thinking that msnbc is
a news organization
if you stop thinking that you can see
the the
you can see reality a lot clearer and
and this is what the red pill is right
when people say well you took the red
pill you swallowed the red bull this is
what it is when you see reality as it is
not as the media is force-feeding it to
be
all right i want to go to uh to clip
number three
they started talking about socialism
that is a hot button issue these days
and let's take it away
your party wants to go socialist party
is me
socialist right now i am and they're
gonna dominate you joe you know that
i am the democratic party right now the
platform of the democratic party
is what i in fact approved of
i am the democratic party right now all
right my star wars people what does that
remind you of
remember palpatine remember revenge of
the sith which i think is
the most underrated of all star wars
movies i think you can make a solid
argument that it's
the third best after uh empire strikes
back in a new hope i think you could put
sith
as number three uh what did emperor
palpatine say
when mace windu and the other three jedi
showed up to arrest him when they found
out that he was the sith
i am the senate that's what he said and
joe biden
i am the democratic party and that
little sleight of hand that he's doing
there it's an interesting move because i
am the democratic party well the
democratic party
uh seems to me the future of the
democratic party seems to be
aoc it seems to be ill on omar it seems
to be reshaded to lead these really
radical leftists now if joe biden you
are the future
are the democratic party then why are
you so afraid of speaking
out against these people and and the
simple truth is he knows that he's
basically the last vestige of some sort
of moderate democrat
um and and he can't really stop this
thing he can't stop this thing
even last night you know he came out he
said i'm not for the green new deal i've
got my own deal on his own website
it says he's for the green new deal but
he knows he can't
really he knows the green new deal is
nonsense and it's an entire rejiggering
of our economy
and it's insanely expensive and cow
farts and
all of this nonsense he knows that but
he can't
turn against the bad guys he's he's
basically he has a deal with the devil
in place
because the deal with the devil is
bernie and and the socialists
bernie and the socialists it would be a
good name for a doo-wop group in the 50s
bernie and the socialists uh basically
i think in effect have said you want our
support well then you're going to have
to do all these things and biden
look usually what happens in a primary
is that a in either side of a primary
right
when you're when you're on the
republican side you have to move more uh
i'll do it this way when you're on the
republican side you have to move more to
the right
right during the primary process because
you got to get the base going and then
usually what happens as a candidate is
you moderate more to the center and on
the left you go more to the left
and that's what happened this time
obviously and then you moderate more to
censor so biden is doing the move
that they always do the issue is he's
not
the democratic party like it ain't
there's just no truth to it anymore
where are the rest of the moderate
voices please show me the list of
moderate democratic voices
that believe in anything that goes
against the big government socialist
stuff i mean they just don't
exist so it's it's a little trickery
basically that that biden is doing there
um i don't think though that trump hit
it hard enough i
i don't trump trump's problem last night
i said this i said this in my uh
post-debate wrap-up
trump's problem last night is he came
out very hostile and aggressive and you
know four years ago when he came out
hustling aggressive he was this
insurgent guy
you know it's like i remember a tweet
that i sent out going
right before one of the debates and
remember that scene in mad max fury road
when there
all the cars are on the road and there's
the guy playing the guitar
and there's flames coming out of it and
i used that gif and i was like that's
trump going to the debate
and it was kind of funny and and
whatever i wasn't i wasn't
voting for trump uh at that time but
there was like this insurgent like sort
of rock
feeling to the whole thing or whatever
trump coming out so angry and indignant
last night i think it doesn't work this
time because now he's the president
right so when you're the outsider and
you're coming in i'm going to drain the
swamp i'm going to do all this stuff
well then
okay you you can you can be kind of
angry and indignant
and me me and all of that stuff when
you're the president
i think he needed to come off as more
presidential that's not necessarily in
a battle his strong suit and i know a
bunch of you are going to say but he's
also fighting the media and i think
that's totally legit
and i'm not the president right so i i
can give you
the best analysis that i can but i'm not
the one up there having to
to fight that monster but i think he's
going to have to at least
at least think about dialing some of it
back because i think what trump's plan
was
basically was i'm going to just attack
the hell out of biden right up front
knowing
that biden when he gets flustered starts
losing his words and getting confused
and everything else and somehow it
didn't happen to biden last night right
so
for all of you uh that have seen all the
clips of biden forgetting things and
screwing up numbers and seemingly
confused as to where he is and
everything else well
i don't know if what they juiced him up
with or what the hell happened but
he whether or he just slept you know
he's called 11 lids
in september meaning that basically at
10 a.m he shuts down for the day so
maybe the guy just freaking slept and
slept and slept and slept
and they gave him a couple a couple
brain supplements they got on amazon
and they threw him out there but
although he lied a lot
and he called trump a racist and the
worst president of u.s history
and and he shut up man and and he was
rude and all of those things and
you know that doesn't that seems more
out of character for him than it would
be for trump let's say
but the problem is that the bar was set
so low and i said this in my pre
debate coverage yesterday the bar was
set so low
that all biden had to do was not implode
up there and then he could be sort of
framed as the winner and he didn't
implode that's the thing
did he lie and will the media yes will
the media call him out on it not really
but trump is gonna have to trump is
gonna have to basically
rethink his strategy that if you can't
knock him
out with that first punch like if you
think about it as a boxing match right
you know depends what your strategy is
some guys want the long game some guys
go for the kill
i think trump is more of like mike tyson
if you remember mike tyson boxing way
back when he went in just to
maul and kill everybody in the first
round and he often did it there's this
incredible
fight versus michael spanx that i'm sure
some of you guys remember he would scare
the hell out of everybody just beat the
crap out of them and that would be it
that was what i think his plan was and
then when it wasn't working i think he
got increasingly frustrated
and and i think chris wallace as i said
before in some ways trump was debating
two-on-one but it was also because he
was so
over the top in his in the jabs and and
the attacks
that i think wallace felt he had to be a
little more on bite inside or something
like that none of this is a
is a perfect science i want to jump in
and then i'm going to do a couple
questions we're going to go a little
long today um uh
when the question came up about critical
race theory which is obviously very big
but but
many people watching the debate are just
hearing about it for the first time
this month your administration directed
federal agencies to end
racial sensitivity training that
addresses
white privilege or critical race theory
why did you decide to do that to end
racial sensitivity training
and do you believe that there is
systemic racism in this country sir
i ended it because it's racist i ended
it because a lot of people were
complaining that they were
asked to do things that were absolutely
insane
that it was a radical revolution that
was taking place
in our military uh in our schools
all over the place and you know it and
so does everybody else
sensitivity training if you were a
certain person
you had no status in life it was sort of
a reversal
and if you look at the people we were
paying people hundreds of thousands of
dollars
to teach very bad ideas and frankly very
sick ideas
and and really they were teaching people
to hate our country
and i'm not going to do that i'm not
going to allow that to happen
okay so those of you that watch this
show you know a bit about
critical race theory i just did a show
that we released last week with chris
ruffo who's one of the best scholars
that we've got on this dissecting what
critical race theory is
i've talked to james lindsey um who also
is one of the great
uh thinkers on this and and the
disassemblers of what critical race
theory is
but chris wallace was was either really
bad
as a as a moderator right there or was
intentionally denying what the truth is
so chris wallace if he's going to ask
the question
about getting critical race theory out
what he's doing there is he's conflating
it
with ending racial sensitivity training
right the implication being that we
should have racial sensitivity training
so people aren't racist well
most of us agree with that and by the
way we don't have any laws in the united
states that encourage racism we don't
have racist
laws on the books of course there are
individual races
critical race theory is injecting race
into everything so trump did answer that
properly it's a hard question
to have to kind of answer on the fly but
critical race theory
is racist if you want more quotas in
government
and with government contractors and you
want people to be hired
because of their race and not because of
their skill set and all of those things
then you should be for critical race
theory but you shouldn't be for critical
race theory because it's antithetical to
everything that the united states is all
about
okay so trump i think his answer was
fine but chris wallace
chris wallace do you not know what
critical race theory is like chris
wallace why didn't you explain for a
moment
that critical race theory is not about
racial sensitivity training meaning
we should treat all uh people of all
races equally
that's what we do that's what we have
laws that are passed
and and laws that are for equality not
equity
equality treat everyone equal what
happens to those people after well it's
a little
it's up to them and hard work and a
little bit of luck and everything else
that is the
the uh gestalt of life right
so that's what you need to be thinking
about and i think chris wallace to
to not he either doesn't know it or
intentionally conflated what it is
the implication being critical race
theory will make people less racist why
aren't you
for it except it is making people more
racist it is injecting racism
into the system so it was it was a
faulty it was a faulty question
and then and then trump you know went
into his thing about
that we should instead of teaching 1619
project we should be teaching 1776
project the idea of being you know being
proud of america
i think we could have a really
interesting debate on
uh whether we should be what level of
patriotism we should be
encouraging whether that should come
from the federal government
or state government and how we teach
history without completely destroying
history i mean those are all interesting
discussions to have but
i don't think we're going to get to too
much more of that in the rest of these
debates
anyway um oh let me do a couple
questions
i told you i do a couple questions and
i'm a man of my word so i will do a
couple questions
so these are questions submitted at
rubinreport.com and i mentioned a couple
times before guys twitter has become
such chaos and the youtube comment
section is
you know you people are not well frankly
uh so if you want to communicate with me
directly
reubenreport.com we're growing a really
great community it's completely troll
free and bot free and the rest of it
and you can submit some questions um
alexis says joe biden appeared to be
more cogent than usual do you think his
calmer more rational presence
will gain him more voters and support
well that's what i referenced earlier
which is
all he had to do was not implode to get
a sort of
default win and i think he did
accomplish that he got very angry at
times he did the usual
you're a racist line you're dumb you
know whatever that kind of stuff
um but he didn't lose himself and i
think that that
caused trump to keep doubling down on
the on the let me go after you go after
you keep punching your thing
and i think trump needed to needed to
think about um
some other methods to to get to biden um
will trumper biden change their
strategies this is from james
what strategies would you recommend for
rounds two and three so i think
trump should try something look it's
hard to tell trump
what to do because trump accomplished
the thing by becoming president that
nobody thought he could do
so a bunch of pundits and think tank
people who've never accomplished
anything in their lives
them all sitting up there saying trump
must do this well it's like you never
accomplished anything the guy became
freaking president of the united states
so he must have some insight into what
he's doing whether you whether you like
him or not i think you have to
acknowledge that
so it's a little hard to tell trump what
to do but i my general take
is that i think more people right now
even the most ardent trump supporter
would like to see him on the debate
stage perhaps a little more confident a
little more calm
not so quick to jump he has a lot of
things to be proud of related to the
economy especially before covet and
record
low black and hispanic on unemployment
before kovid
and uh and oh that that middle east
peace thing
like that would be good so i think
there's a way to come off
as a little more you know i've done some
good stuff you know his best line
trump's best line was in i've done more
in 47 months that's roughly four years
than you've done in 47 years that's a
great line like biden
the idea that biden is going to fix any
of the systemic racism
or any of these things that apparently
have been wrong with america for
hundreds of years
he's been in government for 47 years
he's not going to fix any of these
things
obviously that's where trump i think can
shine as for biden what biden needs to
do more
i don't think there's that much he needs
to do more he needs to make sure he
doesn't have
a mental collapse on stage and then the
media will run cover for him so he can
keep lying about very fine people on
both sides
and the media will run cover so if this
is just about strategy of how you can
win
biden keep resting just just you know
rest that that's about it
um let's see uh i'll do i'll do uh two
more quick ones here i'm
flipping real quick uh who split the
most voters from the other side biden
with his claim that trump caused the
covid deaths
and was all around the worst president
ever or trump by forcing biden to take a
stand
in the democratic civil war so that was
trump's move for sure was trying to
pit every moderate position that biden
would take to say oh you're going to
lose the left and that's why biden said
the thing about i am the democratic
party
i think that was a a pretty sly move by
trump to really just get him to throw
the base under the bus i don't know that
it fully hit but trump definitely should
keep going on that
um biden claiming that all you know all
these deaths are because of trump i
don't think that landed
because you know trump was caught was
calling for
the the china travel lockdown um
and uh and what happened oh there's a
beautiful fact check on cnn about this
you can't make this [ __ ] up i tweeted it
this morning um
on the day that trump called for the
china travel ban
biden called it xenophobic
cnn fact check it fact check that
whether biden called trump xenophobic
and their fact check
basically said something like it's
inconclusive because even though he
called him
xenophobic that exact day he didn't say
in the sentence that it was directly
related
to the travel china ban it's like man
you guys aren't even trying
to try anymore could you just try to try
a little theater would be nice you know
a little theater
would just be nice so i don't know that
either one got any major wins there and
i'll do
one more back um
let's see um dave
will you be moderator for one of these i
think the ship has sailed on that for
this year but i do
think that watching these two guys
watching the format it all feels old
it feels like this thing is just
decaying and breaking down and the
system ain't quite working right
and i do think that although it's not
going to happen
whether it was me heaven forbid or it
was joe rogan or anyone else
it's not gonna happen this round it's
probably not gonna happen for midterms
like people don't really care about
debates during midterms like that but i
do think for
the four years from now election right
the 2024
when trump runs for his third term
because he won't step down
idiot um when when that happens i think
it's going to be very very different i
think the crop of candidates
we're going to have youtubers and
celebrities and some politics people and
authors and influencers and all of that
for better or worse
and i think that the entire structure is
going to have to modify we're just
when you think about the chaos right now
it's because we're in a time when the
institutions and the structures
they they got calcified and then your
voice and youtube and twitter and real
people and diverse thought
it came in right it's like this rush of
pressure and water trying to burst
through the ground but the institutions
are old and crumbled and they're just
trying to hold this thing that they
can't quite hold
and it and it is collapsing and i'm not
someone that wants all the institutions
to burn because we need them to have a
a functional society um so hopefully we
can make some sense of any of this
anyway
please share this video if you thought
that what i said about the both sides
thing of
all made any sense and you know somebody
who doesn't
realize that that actually is the truth
i hope
your heart is beating a little slower at